[Music]
I'll be joined in a little bit by a few
customers and we're gonna talk today
about how you can build top-notch
marketing technology at scale with
Google Cloud but before we get into the
content I'd love to get a sense of who's
in the room so raise your hand if you're
a developer okay there are few of us
raise your hand if you're in sales or in
another business role
okay a little fewer raise your hand if
you work at an advertising or marketing
technology company you're already in
this space awesome great so it's nice to
have all of you in the room and before
we dive into the content I want to start
by level setting a little bit over the
past 10 years there's been an explosion
of new ad tech and Mark tech companies
chief mark tech comm hosts an annual
conference where they talk about the
industry and they document the number of
companies in it in 2016 when they
published this infographic they're about
3,500 companies they just released the
newest infographic a few days ago with
well over 7,000 companies so the growth
of technology in this space has been
supported by CMOS themselves who are
signaling with their wallets a 2018
Gartner CMO study found that CMOS are
now spending more on technology than IT
departments and about a third of
marketing budgets are now spent
completely on technology but even as the
industry grows we're starting to see
much more mergers and acquisitions the
industry is both growing and
consolidating and the reality is even as
the industry sustains enormous growth
new challenges are emerging for the
majority of my career I was working in
the advertising technology space at a
few different companies before Google
and I've had the opportunities to speak
to CMOS at large brands and advertisers
as well as CEOs and CEOs at marketing
technology companies for the past two
years have been focused on our cloud for
marketing initiative helping companies
migrate and re platform to Google cloud
and what I've been hearing from these
businesses these companies is that the
way marketers do business is changing
and I want to highlight two challenges
which are driving this shift the first
challenge is that
marketers are shifting from traditional
advertising to a focus on customer
experience the ask has now become how do
you create a compelling personalized
experience which drives revenue while
also adhering to security and privacy
regulations marketers and CMOS see where
the ball is going and according to a
2017 Gartner survey 81% of marketers
expect to be competing mostly or
completely on the basis of customer
experience in two years time and in two
years time that's now right so
enterprises and the enterprise's need to
be more thoughtful about how they're
managing customer data this means new
processes new methods new ways of
tackling these challenges and in this
new world of customer experience it's
really high stakes because the risk is
that if you get this wrong you degrade
user trust whether your user is a
publisher or a user at the other end of
a computer screen the second challenge
in this ecosystem is that
differentiation is becoming increasingly
get difficult why this is actually
caused by what I would say two main
reasons the first is just the crowded
nature of the ecosystem there are more
and more companies we saw in that first
slide the infographic more and more
companies competing and specializing in
the same space as competition and scale
increases Marge's margins start to get
compressed and companies start to have
to do more with less at the same time
the speed of innovation is increasing as
the world becomes more as the world and
technology becomes more efficient
advertising becomes more efficient and
more and more competitors migrate to the
cloud they become more agile better able
to respond to business needs according
to a 2018 study by seismic marketers
actually show a clear preference for
working with fewer vendors in the space
which means it's more important than
ever to stand out and you need a Google
cloud you need a cloud platform that can
help you do that so responding to this
changing ecosystem requires a change in
mindset and a different way of thinking
about how you build your technology
companies are just like humans companies
are made up of humans we like to do
things that are comfortable things that
are easy and most of the time that means
maintaining the status quo doing
things the same way you did it
previously but maintaining the status
quo isn't a recipe for success and
taking a new approach often requires
making real change that will enable you
to actually grow and differentiate your
business Google cloud is a technology
that's been built to help businesses
transform and it's actually just an
external version of the technology and
capabilities that Google has built over
the years to support both our
advertising and our consumer facing
products you can think of Google cloud
like the invisible support beams that
help to make all the cool things the
Google does possible it's a safe
reliable and scalable place for
companies to build and innovate whether
you're moving an entire marketing
platform marketing technology business
or just migrating one small data and
analytics workload it's also a platform
that has close ties to our advertising
business and this is huge benefits for
companies in the marketing technology
space because you can decide how you
want to partner with us whether that's
as an integration layer or whether
that's with a joint go to market plan in
fact we've already worked with a number
of companies in this space and we've
seen great success Mixpanel is actually
a San Francisco based analytics company
they tracked user interactions over web
and app and they're focused on driving
and measuring user engagement and
retention they are an analytics company
company and they had hugely demanding
workloads their average customer query
was scanning about 50,000 events and
some of their queries could reach as
much as 10 10 billion events the problem
is as they scaled they ran into huge
issues with their bare-metal servers
they weren't able to reach the same
performance they were running into
service server down times server
downtime and system failures so they
made the decision to migrate to Google
cloud and they were able to achieve
higher performance and achieve the scale
that they needed to support their
enterprise customers they wanted to
maintain a median query time of one
second for each query in order to
maintain that real-time analytics and I
think the interesting part about this
story it's not up on the slide but they
actually were able to reclaim
30 to 50% of engineering time for
engineering product development which is
huge when you're thinking about ways
that you can innovate and grow your
business reclaiming 50% of engineering
time is amazing so companies like
Mixpanel see huge benefits from
partnering with Google in ways like
achieving global scale while reducing
infrastructure costs they're able to
analyze valuable data and drive growth
and also a future proof their business
with our smart secure and open platform
and I want to dive into a few of these
topics so I want to speak a little bit
about our purpose-built infrastructure
Google cloud has the most extensive
cloud network with the farthest reach we
have over a hundred points of presence
if you've been to our keynote or been to
any other sessions I'm sure you've heard
a lot about this this means that we have
higher availability lower latency and
better security and especially when
you're thinking about reaching the right
user at the right time with the right
message it's key to maintain that scale
while being secure at the same time and
our network can definitely help you do
that aside from our network products we
have an entire suite of data products
that are tailor-made for whatever
challenges you face whether that's
needing to query petabytes of data or in
just millions of rows per second the
cool thing here is that as a cloud
customer you have direct access to the
software systems that we've built for
our ads ads business and many of these
products were a bigquery data proc
spanner pub stub BigTable all can manage
the scale four of our ads products and
you can use them today open standards
with proprietary performance these
products also make it easy for you to
share your data with your customers
which is really important with your
customer experience hat on if you're
thinking about getting all of your
customer data or as helping your
customers get all their data in the same
place on a dive a bit into BigTable
raise your hand if you're familiar with
BigTable okay good so if you're not
familiar BigTable is a fast globally
distributed wide column no sequel
database and if all of that sounds like
gibberish ooh that's fine
basically this means that BigTable is a
super low latency database that's
sooo the information exactly when you
need it globally and so when you were
thinking about ad tech companies mark
tech companies who we need to serve up
in real time BigTable is a product
that's super super helpful for that and
it's also fully managed this means your
engineers can focus on building new
features new tools new products rather
than maintaining a database like
bigquery
lastly BigTable provides easy
integration with open source big data
tools so it's completely compatible with
existing Apache HBase setups and other
Apache services like spark and storm
keeping on that theme the entire Google
cloud platform is built to support your
business and the way that you work where
whatever your cloud capabilities are or
wherever you are on your journey so over
the past 10 years Google has been super
intentional in our support of open
source product projects from early work
in containers to Linux to github to
Python so this means when you choose
Google Cloud you're not locked in and if
you saw our keynote this morning you
heard a lot about that with some of our
new announcements but basically we want
to help you do what you want to do and
use our products in the ways that
supports your business best so you can
use gke on-prem to create a single pane
view for managing all your clusters
regardless of where they are and this
leaves you free to migrate what makes
sense for you but also give you
flexibility and control so to summarize
Google Cloud is built from the bottom up
to help you build smarter and innovate
faster whether that's providing a unique
customer experience or analyzing data to
help your customers receive richer
insights
it's a powerful platform that's built to
build helped you build a better version
of your business and I want to bring up
a few customers to share about how
they're using Google cloud why they
choose Google cloud and what they're
building next so I'd love to invite up
Paul Ryan the CTO of open X put your
hands together
[Applause]
thank you
hello I'm Paul so what is open X okay
open X is an ad exchange what does that
mean that means we get around 2.5
trillion requests for ads a month which
translate into four point five trillion
specific events per day that we track we
work with publishers the supply side and
help them fill their inventory slots we
reach out to the demand side a couple of
hundred folks that are proxies for
advertisers okay and so it's a big
exchange high volume transaction
processing lots of things going on lots
of moving parts open X o is a hundred
percent on Prem right now and we're
migrating into gcp as we speak we're
testing in Singapore for what we call
call our delivery sites our front end
exchange site which actually runs the
auction so why would a company this
large with such demanding online
transaction processing requirements like
move to the clouds in the cloud like way
more expensive and it's not going to
work and how is it going to scale to the
workloads that you need so we had all
these questions pretty much at the
beginning of 2018 and so we went on a
journey to figure out specifically how
the public cloud might help us
potentially in a hybrid mode with a
little bit of Investigation we said well
what the hell why go hybrid why don't we
see what it looks like if we're fully in
the public cloud okay and so I'm going
to talk a little bit about that journey
give you a little bit more background on
OpenX
and why we decided to use GCP so on the
publisher side we work with basically
all the largest publishers in the world
people that really want to fulfill their
ad requirements and actually generate
revenue so obviously it's a very
demanding client set and there's some
unique challenges working with both the
publishers and the demand side of the ad
tech ecosystem and frankly if you look
at the Loomis
or that or the the chart that we just
saw there's thousands of players but
fundamentally when a user is on an app
or on a publisher site potentially
they're working through a JavaScript
container to call out to lots of
different exchanges okay that each call
out to a lot of different demand-side
platforms which are representing brands
for advertising so this diagram is like
it tells you kind of the problem set
there's a tremendous amount of
networking going on there's a tremendous
amount of requests going out and then
you've got to process them save all the
requests and the responses to figure out
oh who won the auction did you get an
impression and who do you pay the money
to and who do you bill so that's kind of
the the ecosystem there's tons of tech
there's lots of different companies
involved and actually you know EB is
exchange bidding that's Google and so
Google is heavily involved in the
programmatic ecosystem so what's really
needed to win in programmatic is you
have to have a global footprint even 100
percent on Prem we have five data
centers worldwide because you have to be
close to the supply side the client the
consumer the the person using the app
that latency is very important but you
also have to be close to the demand side
because you're requesting bids from them
and so you're kind of you kind of have
to place things in the middle around the
world in order to get the best
performance okay you want the lowest
latency as I said to the endpoints and
consumers that you're using and and
frankly it's got to be flexible I mean
if our average CPU utilization on Prem
is like 20% that's all you need to know
right it's it's a 5x trough to peak
universe and gosh isn't that
auto-scaling
can't you you do something about that
and it's really real time and I call web
scale so at a given any given moment we
could be up to two to million requests
per second and as I said more than four
trillion events so this is a pretty
demanding set of workloads so how do you
select a public cloud provider there's
only three easy steps right
everything's three easy steps so you
identify the providers that
have a worldwide footprint and can
operate at that scale okay and
realistically there's probably three or
two-and-a-half right maybe two and three
quarters so identify the usual suspects
that you would see in the gartner
quadrant up to the right then you
actually have to do a proof of concept
because your mileage will vary okay
depending on the critical components of
your infrastructure you know they're
gonna behave differently regardless of
whether you're using kubernetes on pram
or your hundred per second one hundred
percent containerized it's going to be a
little bit different the bang for the
buck in instances will be different the
networking profile will be different so
you've got a POC some stuff and then you
know you model it you figure out if it's
going to work you work with the CFO to
convince them that not having capex is a
good thing right because all of a sudden
you're cogs go up because it's all
variable right and so you have to have
that discussion on a cash flow basis it
might be fantastic but you know from an
EBIT table point of view it may not be
so you have to have all those
discussions model it and actually
negotiate so we did a whole series of
POCs with the three usual suspects in
terms of our front end which is as I
said running the auction okay so we took
four or five of our major components and
ran them in all the public clouds and
then peered directly with our coalos to
MIT for all the other services for the
150 other services that we use and ran
real production loads against it
changing up sizes and figuring out how
we would you know potentially scale
stuff and there's some relatively
meaningless graphs up there on you know
don't read anything into it but we
actually performance checked it ran it
up to a around a thousand QPS just to
see how the different profiles work on
the back end are our daily you know our
hourly ETL process which is really this
enormous
MapReduce set of MapReduce jobs with
some spark stuff in
there we took that and said okay here's
an hour here's two hours here's three
hours of raw transaction data let's see
how much we can scale things like EMR or
data proc to see if we can actually do
that workload in less than an hour okay
so these were the two major components
you know can we run an auction and can
we actually process the data
so what are we discovered about GCP well
the network latency in GCP in general is
just outstanding okay to everyone in the
programmatic ecosystem to Google of
course and why should anyone find that
surprising if you're in programmatic
advertising is it in your interest to be
pure very well with Google and GCP of
course right so if you're in that
infrastructure your latency is fantastic
you get pretty good bang for the buck on
the VMS and we could do this across the
different cloud platforms figure out for
a given workload what do we need to do
the other thing is remember I said we're
doing this periodic hourly thing where I
might need 30 to 50,000 cores to do
something well you know if it takes
somebody two weeks to try to get that
test to run that kind of is an
indication they don't have enough
resources to actually run the business
so that was a availability of large
resources and frankly the open
open-source support with things like
kubernetes it's just it's undeniable so
that's kind of why we chose Google Cloud
thank you well thank you for joining for
this session we at library amp had a
very similar story to open ax in terms
of the process that we went through in
looking at cloud solutions the decision
to move to the cloud and our decision to
use Google so libraries business the way
we operate we're really this data and
identity foundation for marketers you
heard Andreea talk about the fact that
today marketers are focused on how did
they build incredible customer
experiences and in order to do that they
need
be able to harness all of their data
across all of the interactions that
they're having with their customers and
be able to leverage that data to make
better decisions and interact with our
customers in more meaningful ways so
we're a key foundational middleware
layer that enables brands to bring
together all of the data that they know
about their customers segmented create
audiences and then activate it across
any range of ad tech and Mar tech
technologies so to give you some history
about we're live ramp came from we had
built out a all of our technology was in
a single colos facility based in San
Francisco we have about a hundred
petabytes of servers in our colocation
facility and we were hitting this point
where we were scaling really really
quickly as a business we needed to be
able to expand to new markets expand our
products more quickly launch new
products faster and just continue to
innovate and grow because we're in a
very high growth phase and we were
hitting limitations with the fact that
we had all of our data and all of our
services within our a1 colocation
facility which was getting difficult to
manage and we weren't able to order
servers fast enough in order to keep up
with our growth so we recognized a
couple of years ago that we actually
really needed to move to the cloud and
then we went through a very rigorous
process of looking at what are the
different solutions out there what do we
think our needs are and how do we and do
we want to go with like a hybrid
solution do we want to go all-in on the
cloud and essentially it came down to
two different two parts to decision
making factors one was looking at what
was the technology available and then
one was looking at what are the costs
associated with that and we did a pretty
extensive model where we were looking
very specifically at the kinds of
technologies that we would use within
each cloud provider how much scale we
would need for that modeling like what
we thought the price was going to be
based on our various conversations with
different cloud providers evaluating the
technologies for the scale that we are
operate
and we're while we have many
similarities in terms of the scale we're
operating at to open X we have key
differences we're not doing a lot of
real-time Network we don't have the same
kind of real-time networking challenges
we're doing a lot of big data processing
on huge amounts of amounts of data that
we're coming in so the way our product
works is we work with hundreds of brands
take all of their data are processing
that data activating it across hundreds
of platforms bringing data back in from
those platforms and giving that back to
the brand or putting that into different
measurement solutions so we're
processing just tons and tons of data
every single day and so a lot of the
challenges that we face where as like
are the challenges that we have are
fairly different than a lot of other
companies that are that are storing a
lot of data and processing a lot of data
for instance like when we thought about
moving to the cloud one of the
challenges we had is all we're basically
a data processing company so we don't
have a lot of data that's in cold
storage we have a lot of data that is
live and it's moving through a pipeline
and so we when we're migrating we're
thinking about what is this going to
look like we have to think about how do
we do this without disrupting our
clients and so there are a lot of
challenges that we had to go through and
thinking through this process the key
thing that we were thinking about is
like how do we expand our business how
do we continue to grow and a key part of
what we're focused on is we're a company
all about helping people activate their
data we have 550 integrations today
across a broad range of categories and
for us we have to think about like how
do we build these integrations faster
how do we improve the way we're pushing
and pulling data from all of these
different ecosystem players and how do
we just continue to offer more and more
use cases to our clients so all of this
came into this is was part of our
thought processes we were thinking about
moving to the cloud and being able to
offer products and innovate faster as we
also looked at what are the growth
factors for us there are a lot of growth
vectors
again we're a very high-growth company
some of the ones that I wanted to point
out here is international expansion we
really needed the ability to expand
internationally as quickly as possible
and with all of the data privacy
regulation coming into effect we had to
think about like how do we have more
data available just in region how do we
create the right permissions around it
other parts of our growth are really
focused around data sharing so our data
store product enables companies to
monetize their products our second party
data products enable brands to share the
data with each other in secure data
partnerships and these are these are
products that we had to think about like
how are we gonna build how we're gonna
create the right permissions around this
and all of this would factored into the
way we thought about picking our cloud
provider so why did we end up choosing
Google there are many reasons at play as
I talked about it was it was both a
technology decision and a cost decision
and when we started doing the evaluation
on the technology itself and we thought
about hey what's most important to our
clients what it came down to was
security like when we're talking about
data partnerships and we're taking we're
taking into into our system valuable
data from a very broad swath of the
ecosystem and people expect that data to
be protected they expect that data to be
safe and we evaluated the the security
practices and we have very rigorous
security practices for ourselves in our
colocation facility we had to think
about like how are we gonna port that
over to the cloud and we were really
impressed by the security that Google
had in place and we've actually been
able to up the game in terms of our
security practices and unlock a whole
new set of use cases for us especially
as we get into more regulated industries
and are opening up new use cases by
working with Google the second thing for
us is like you know we have evolved very
quickly but we're still a 10 year old
companies so we had to do an immense
amount of infrastructure modernization
and we went through a big process even
before we started migrating of container
izing all of our all of our code one of
the things that have we've really
appreciated and partnering with Google
is that they've been able to provide as
professional
services and other advisory around how
to actually migrate our systems to the
cloud which has actually sped up the
process for us so we signed our our GCP
agreement in July of last year we are
hoping to be fully on track to be fully
migrated by the end of August this year
so we've gone through a pretty fast
process and we've had lots of different
pieces that we've had to migrate we have
our core systems here in the US we have
systems internationally that have that
are slightly different and so we've had
many different environments that we've
had to move over and as part of that
really thought about how do we how do we
monetize our infrastructure the other
thing that's really important to us is
like I said we're a big data processing
company so looking at the tools that are
available within Google and recognizing
that we can be part of the roadmap of
developing those tools to better suit
our business was a critical component
and underlying all of that there's the
people that we worked with when you're
entering into a relationship of this
size and this is a substantial
investment for us financially into it's
going to help us improve our gross
margins we're thinking about like how
does this improve our partnership
opportunities this is very very
fundamental to our business and so we
were looking for someone we could really
partner with and someone who would lean
in with us and really help us innovate
faster and know that if we had an issue
we could pick up the phone and call
someone and and get help for what we
needed to and honestly throughout this
migration process that we've been
through we it keeps getting reinforced
that the people that we're working with
at Google are just amazing and the
technical expertise are able to bring to
the table and bring to our engineering
team has helped us migrate really
quickly and I think it bodes really well
for the future as we continue to think
about innovation the last part that I
think is really important and Paul
mentioned this as well is our part
overall partnership with Google for us
we've had a very long-standing
relationship with the ads side of the
Google business and we connect tons of
data into Adwords and to double-click
and into some of the newer products
within the Google ad stack as well and
we were thinking about how do we want to
who do we want to partner with for the
future for us it was an obvious decision
to partner with Google because it brings
us closer to the googles Google's
business but also because we see so many
of our customers and partners adopting
solutions on top of Google and when
we're talking about integrating data if
we're all integrated on top of the same
technology stack it makes that
integration so much easier it makes a
data flow so much faster and these are
all things that we're considering as
we're looking to the future and making
sure that we have a partner who's really
gonna help us grow the business thank
you
now I'd like to introduce Michael from
urban airship hi yes I'm Mike Carrick
I've run technology for urban airship
and we're a little bit ahead of these
two companies in terms of our journey
our started three years ago at least for
me it did three years ago here at next
where I met with Google we had been
evaluating them we had previously been
80% in a Colo facility and 20% on EWS
and so our Colo was very quickly
deteriorating underneath us we were
dealing with failing hard drives failing
networks and it was time to reap lat
form and we were considering either
adding a couple coalos and investing in
more hardware or fully moving to the
cloud and thankfully we made a great
choice and and moved to Google it was a
gigantic undertaking but we we chose it
just given you know all the great
technology fit we used to run a ton of
HBase and HBase migrated really well to
BigTable and that was really important
to us
the migration really went well I'll tell
you a bit of a bit more about it but it
it really helped us manage cost it's
really hard to manage costs in a Colo
I'm for a SAS company it really helped
us make our platform more scalable I'll
show you some
about that and more reliable which
really can't say enough about that in
terms of just the quality of life of our
engineers and just the customer
satisfaction that we now enjoy and also
now that we're on the other side of it
we no longer are doing crazy things like
balancing Cassandra rings and HBase
clusters and tuning Kafka and so our
engineers are able now to innovate much
further up the stack which is which is
great
so just briefly a little bit about urban
airship
urban airship is a customer engagement
platform so we focused primarily on
things like retention and growth for our
customers we helped a little bit on the
acquisition side but mostly focused on
those two things we started you may know
us we were the original third-party push
notification company but we've expanded
dramatically and create many different
types of experiences these days we
expanded into you know various in app
experiences we work with Google and
Apple on things like Google pay so
mobile wallets yeah we power a lot of
your boarding passes probably if you
flew some of the Airlines that we
support we do things on the web email
SMS some other channels as well and we
operate at a pretty great scale ad Tech
is the only thing that ever makes me
feel small but we send you know 90
billion messages a month across these
channels and you know regularly exceed
500 thousand messages a second and our
customer base we're pretty much geared
for enterprise all the way of customers
large and small and we have you know 25%
of the fortune 100 our customers really
briefly this is a look at our platform
we talked a bit about channels we we
support many of them we also have this
open channel API that a number of our
customers use to reach on things like
over-the-top networks that they can't
reach through any other way and so
that's nice technology and we've been
investing heavily in our orchestration
layer so that's all sorts of things
targeting segmentation automation and
orchestration across channels optimizing
them and then last all these experiences
that we help our customers create send
back a lot of first party data to urban
airship and we help them make use of
that by providing rich user profiles
performance analytics on that data
machine learning and AI capabilities
things like predictive churn some time
optimization and then we have some
technology to stream any of this data
that we process out to our customers
other aspects of their marketing
technology stack things like BI tools
some of our customers used to send it to
ad networks that that sort of thing so a
couple examples of experiences that we
provide we work across verticals so
travel retail media financial I
mentioned a lot of Airlines our point of
view is the best marketing isn't really
marketing at all it's these useful types
of experiences where you can provide
value and experiences that users value
so you know in travel you know things
like hey your seat has been upgraded and
retail your package has shipped media a
story that you're interested in because
you're following a journalist financial
you know here's your your account
balance so we do all sorts of things
like that most recently just last night
I put this in there because it was
timely and the NCAA is a customer and so
we powered of their March Madness
messaging so they do a great job with
anything from squirrel Ertz to sending
videos through rich notifications to
even last night after the game you know
the kind of famous one shining moment
video was sent out so we we were busy
last night another quick story so so
last year for the World Cup soon after
we finished our migration to Google
cloud we had a bunch of customers that
were really excited about the world come
one in one in particular one football
really wanted to make sure that you know
their notifications arrived as quickly
as possible so we we worked closely with
them on some technology that we call
boost and this is just a graph this was
the end of the World Cup last year we
were sending you know four hundred
thousand notifications a second four
minutes that's like that's across our
customer base we power tons of media and
sports apps since then you know we've
exceeded this milestone and regularly
exceed five hundred note of five hundred
thousand notifications a second but just
to lift the hood up a bit
I won't delve into too much detail but
this is a look at one of our subsystems
we call it the CDP the core delivery
platform so it's you know the the scale
that we operate means that we we have to
do a lot of things that maybe we wish we
wouldn't have to in terms of
micro-services and really kind of
breaking some of these components apart
so we have what we call a distributed
query planner which deals with a lot of
these subsystems and it leverages a
bunch of google technology like BigTable
we leverage a ton of cloud pub/sub and
also compute engine but by leveraging
Google technology again compared back to
our Colo we were able to easily add
capacity for the World Cup we can scale
it up and down and we also were able to
leverage you know some of our own
innovation by doing a bunch of stop
software optimization to you know do a
lot of parallel processing some advanced
queueing of some of these priority
requests and so by doing that you know
we were able to really meet our
customers needs I think if we hadn't
completed our move to Google cloud just
because the World Cup was so so big for
our business you know it probably
wouldn't have gone nearly as well so
that was great so I mentioned that we we
started our journey 80% on Colo 20% on
Amazon we're expanding our footprint
more globally now so we're moving into
additional regions and so it just made
sense for a second
holiday we've had somewhat success with
Google our engineers really love it and
so we've just collapsed the stack this
is one of the projects that our team is
working on right now we're migrant we
have a business intelligence capability
so it's really fine-grained user level
data at the event level so just tons and
tons of data and it had been running on
it's currently running on redshift and
has been for a couple years and that's
worked okay but we're really our
customers love this product they want to
see better performance they want a
fresher data and so BigTable and
bigquery are really helping us deliver
on that for our customers and so
currently we're loading this data daily
just because it's so much and just given
some of the economics that at least we
experience with redshift but we're gonna
be able to move that to minutes instead
of per day so our customers has they've
been hearing about this news they're
pretty excited and also our storage is
now separated from compute if you know
anything about redshift this will make
sense to you so we can say goodbye to
nodes in reserved instances which is
great for our cost index you know just
from a complexity standpoint you know
some of this is just the way we built
the system we're doing a lot of software
updates to this as well but you know
with this new version of the system you
know we're moving from some complicated
ETL that we kind of crafted from Kinesis
and microservices to one one single
dataflow job so just really dramatically
simplifies the system and then just our
our maintenance overhead is reduced like
we don't have to deal with vacuums
anymore which has been less than awesome
and then bigquery cluster tables really
enable efficient queries versus and
we've had to do for some of the queries
given the complexity of the data have to
do a lot of scanning of the entire data
set which is really slow so that's great
so and then as we kind of look to the
future and we have big aspirations for
our company and creating more and more
capabilities and our customer engagement
platform
and so we're you know seeking to
leverage more and more of Google cloud
you know right now all of our machine
learning capabilities are built in-house
and we're experimenting with leveraging
some of the Google stuff you know our
job is to innovate further up the stack
and not bother with things like managing
HBase and hard drives so anyways that's
my story
thank you
[Music]